[Music]
say Venn wants to move the stable from
point A to point B what will he do yes
he will push it in the direction of
point B you see that as he pushes the
table it starts moving anything around
us that moves we say that it's in motion
so this table is in motion and since Ben
is also moving along with the table he
is also in motion in our day to day life
we see various things moving around us
simple examples that I can give are
vehicles moving on the road people
walking across streets birds flying in
the sky and so on do you know that the
earth and the other planets also undergo
motion yes they are revolving around the
Sun you can give me thousands of such
examples of motion but what if I ask you
to tell me the definition of motion how
can we define something as intuitive as
motion of a body well for that we need
to look at what exactly happens to a
body but it's in motion let's say this
vehicle moves from point A to point B
you see that as it's moving towards B
its position in space changes with time
initially it was here then here and now
after some time it's here notice what's
changing the position of the object and
the time - which is changing anyway the
change in position of a body with time
is what we call motion in simple words
whenever there's a change in position of
a body we say it's either undergoing
motion or has undergone motion let's
discuss about the different types of
motion now the simplest type of motion
is called a rectilinear motion notice
that there is a word line in there so we
defined this type of motion as a motion
in a straight line yes
rectilinear motion is nothing but motion
in a straight line so if an object is
moving along this straight line path we
say that it's performing rectilinear
motion for example
when a car is moving in a straight line
on a straight road it's performing
rectilinear motion there is one more
thing that I want to discuss with you in
this video
assume you're on a railway platform
watching the train pass by you are at
rest for you both the train as well as
the passengers sitting in sight are in
motion but will the people sitting
inside the train say the same about the
other passengers in the train for a
person sitting inside the people in the
train are not moving they are at rest so
for the observer at rest on the platform
the people inside the Train are moving
but for the person sitting inside they
are at rest what does this tell us this
means that the motion of any object is
relative to the observer for different
observers the motion may be different we
will learn more about this in higher
grades in this video we understood the
definition of motion we also discussed
one of the types of motion called
rectilinear motion in the next video we
will see a few other types of motion
[Music]
you